nous avec nous sur ce studio catherine
deneuve bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes en partie cette votre présence
s'explique en partie par la défense que
voudriez faire de certains producteurs
européens qui prennent des risques en
défendant des petits films notamment le
portugais paulo branco
oui j'aurais bien voulu être à
strasbourg ce soir mais je tournais
encore hier un film en belgique donc je
ne peux pas être à la soirée aujourd'hui
on rend hommage à paolo branco qui est
un producteur portugais qui a produit
beaucoup de films boxing en europe
beaucoup de films de langue étrangère
mais des films européens des films
parfois tourner aussi en france et c'est
quelqu'un de très de très audacieux de
créer de très cinéphile et je trouve je
suis très très contente parce qu'il est
quand même très jeunes et les
producteurs depuis très longtemps mais
il est très jeune
je suis très contente qu'on lui rende un
hommage aussi important aujourd'hui à
strasbourg à son âge me choque c'est
très très bien
alors au delà des initiatives
courageuses de certains producteurs
comme comme ce portugais qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour défendre
le cinéma européen
qu'est ce que vous attendez puisque vous
avez avec vous catherine trautmann
précisément des pouvoirs publics par
exemple je suis pas vraiment là je crois
franchement pour parler à ce niveau là
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce
qu'a dit catherine trautmann et sur les
engagements qui ont été pris je pense
qu'il ya déjà beaucoup de choses qui
sont faites en france pour soutenir le
cinéma français et c'est vrai que si le
cinéma français dans une situation quand
même encore possible c'est vrai qu'il ya
quand même des systèmes qui permettent
aux eaux film d'exister de se tourner à
des auteurs et des réalisateurs de faire
le film dans des conditions quand même
assez assez formidable aujourd'hui mais
c'est vrai que le problème se pose aussi
au niveau de la distribution
c'est vrai que nous on a un système qui
fait que de toute façon les quotas sont
tellement importants que beaucoup des
films français passent à la télévision
donc il ya une demande une nécessité
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya aussi un
problème au niveau de la de la diffusion
des films de la distribution et que et
je sais par exemple que par l'eau branco
encore lui a acheté une salle de cinéma
qui est une salle mythique jeudi pour
les cinéphiles qui est l'action
république et donc il va faire de la
distribution ce sera une chose
évidemment très limité puisque c'est un
cinéma d'art et d'essai avec tout ce que
ça comporte je veux dire de deux limites
par rapport à un grand public mais je
pense que c'est au niveau de la
distribution c'est vrai qu'il faudrait
que il
un effort de fait pour soutenir
peut-être davantage les films français
mais je ne pense pas qu'on puisse éviter
le raz-de-marée américain mais c'est
vrai qu'il n'ya pas de raison par
exemple que moi quand je vais aux états
unis je suis sidéré de voir quand même
qu'ils aient si peu de films étrangers
ils sont quand même eux je trouve très
protectionniste vis-à-vis de leur cinéma
en amérique très produits sont très très
très fermé quand même donc je trouve
normal qu'on fasse un effort pour
soutenir le cinéma européen
la nemo catherine trautmann vous êtes
sûrs et non de strasbourg est ce que
c'est pas une sorte de combat
donquichottesque justement vu encore une
fois la puissance des grands maîtres
joueurs américains et puis le poids de
la langue anglaise dans le monde c'est
pas rien même mais la langue française
les langues européennes l'italien le
portugais mais il faut penser aussi que
quand même les langue française tout en
amérique du sud veut dire par l'espagnol
l'europe c'est aussi l'espagnol est tout
amérique du sud le mexique tous ces pays
sont concernés une partie du canada dont
vous êtes très injuste j'espère que
c'est pas un combat trautmann non je
pense vous battre contre des moulins à
vent non je ne pense pas me battre
contre un moulin à vent
d'autant plus que ce que je constate
c'est que le public lorsqu'il a le choix
s'est aussi appréciée des films de
création on le voit en ce moment dans le
succès d'un certain nombre de films
distribués en salles
je voudrais en même temps si vous me le
permettez c'est lui le travail que fait
catherine denave auprès de l'unesco pour
valoriser et engager l'ensemble des pays
à protéger et restaurer et diffuser le
patrimoine cinématographique je crois
que c'est extrêmement important que
l'ensemble du public est taxé à une
connaissance du film a une histoire ça
peut lui permettre aussi de former son
regard de comprendre aujourd'hui la
place que tient le film pour comprendre
notre société et la regarde et peut-être
avec un air plus humains je crois
beaucoup que le cinéma peut apporter
il est à la fois oeuvre de création il
est en même temps aussi un regard sur le
monde et si la télévision un peu
supplanté les écrans ça je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il a encore de beaux
jours devant lui
merci beaucoup catherine trautmann
excusez moi effectivement j'étais
troublé par votre présence catherine
deneuve et j'ai oublié de rappeler aux
téléspectateurs que je travaille
effectivement pour une mission les je
trouve que c'est très important de
rappeler parce que quand on a quand on
l'a fait l'anniversaire du cinéma on a
fêté les 50 ans du cinéma ça paraît très
très vieux
or c'est le 7e art c'est vraiment l'art
le plus jeune qui existe et le cinéma
est vraiment l'art le plus populaire
donc c'est vrai qu'il faut penser qu'il
n'y aura pas de dahra populaire qui
restera s'il n'y a pas de mémoire
et s'il n'y a pas de souvenirs donc si
on ne fait pas des efforts pour
préserver le patrimoine qui est très
fragile et très coûteux à conserver donc
je compte beaucoup sur la générosité des
sponsors publics et de noé sponsors
privés par d'euros pour aider à la
restauration du patrimoine oui merci
beaucoup
catherine trautmann merci beaucoup
catherine deneuve